[Music]
she had these two Christmas ornaments
that are so foul they have to be blurred
on the
video and she gave me and then she put
this uh on my door which I thought was a
Christmas decoration but sah it was a
name tag Sarah says it's a name
tag Merry
Christmas it is the most it's the most
fun
tradition you heard
it
they said it not me I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report it is December 19th
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals postgame show as
always Ruben report. locals.com before
we get to it today I'm very excited our
new hire Joey is officially in studio
with us College Dropout we do not go to
the Ivy Leagues to bring in the M kids
we find College dropouts from New Jersey
we bring them down here to the free
state of Florida they make a better life
for themselves that's what we do here at
the Ruben report it is Joey's first day
so we're very excited about that uh the
theme of the program today and this is a
big one I can tell you this might be the
most amount of paper I've ever had at my
desk at one time there's a lot of words
on these on these papers and I'm going
to see what I can do with them uh the
theme of today is that the oldw World BS
artist Hollywood woke driil people are
on full attack on everyone and
everything that is good uh and in this
case we're going to start with a clip of
John Oliver John Oliver I guess he's got
this show on Max or HBO he was on The
Daily Show once British guy moved to
America to just complain about how evil
America is uh he did a half hour
dissertation I guess they call it a
comedy or something but he did a half
hour prepackaged all written he goes
direct to the camera like I do but it's
all written by a bunch of other people
he's probably got 2030 writers over
there just trying to take out Elon Musk
and Elon Musk as you know I don't have
to hit this too hard for you guys Elon
Musk is the guy defending free speech at
Twitter he's the guy building the
electric cars he's the guy sending us to
Mars he's the guy working on neurolink
and starlink and a whole bunch more uh
but we're going to connect how the
system goes after every one doing good
and then of course if you're also doing
good it's not that they'll try to just
cancel you and take you out and go after
your business and all that they'll also
connect you to that Adolf Hitler guy
they'll tell you that you're a Nazi uh
and they will try to scare basically
everyone that is a freedom loving
American uh that is what we're going to
get to and uh we're also going to
connect that to what's going on in our
cities right now because there were more
massive just crazy pramas protests in
New York City last night and forgot god
sakes people if you live in New York
City and you're sane just get out
nobody's coming to save you nobody is
coming to save you Dave will save you if
you move down here to Florida isn't that
right Joey yes it is you see okay so
that's what we're doing today let's dive
right into it so John Oliver he's a
comedian I have to call this guy a
comedian anyway here's a guy who he's
just like this dorky whatever who just
sits in front of a camera and reads what
they tell him uh to read here he is
going after Elon Musk it's just a small
portion but you'll see just how it's
just so pathetic and transparent and I'm
only showing this to you so you know
more of the tactics of how the system
operates when someone tries to be good
the fact is whether we like it or not
and the answer is absolutely not a huge
number of very important things going
forward are going to depend on how Elon
is feeling which is a terrifying thing
to say about anyone but especially this
guy so so what can be done here well
it's actually simple we just create a
robot infrastructure economy that can
resist Easy monopolization by private
firms headed by overconfident
billionaires and we do it about 15 years
ago two problems with that one time
machines don't exist and two the only
person with the resources and ambition
to build one is the last guy that you'd
want to do that because he' probably use
it to go back in time and high five Baby
Hitler and look I'll be honest my
feelings about Elon changed a bit in the
writing of this piece I'm probably now
more impressed by what he's doing but
more worried by the fact that he's the
one who's been doing it because he
cultivates an image that he's simply too
Visionary too original to play by other
people's rules and he waves away the
damage that he does as the cost of
innovation and saving Humanity but the
truth is that way of thinking isn't
remotely original we've seen it so many
times before the least surprising thing
on earth is a middle-aged billionaire
CEO with self-serving libertarian views
increasingly racist politics and a
messiah complex and it is long past time
that he faced the kind of accountability
that should come with that and not just
from the echo chamber that he bought
himself online but from everyone whose
lives are very much affected by him I
know Elon might be unhappy with this
piece he he might even permanently
delete my Twitter account which is fine
by me after all when this absolute
treasure is gone elon's the one who will
have to explain why to the
Earth and he might say he's saving
Humanity what have I ever done what
industries have I revolution and I admit
nothing yet but may I remind you I've
already taken the first step toward
building a robot Empire Bow Down and
Worship your Metal Gods bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce why do I do this to
the audience they don't watch these
shows in their own lives and then they
come to this show and I make them watch
this crap these people the reason I'm
showing you this is because for whatever
influence these people have all they do
is try to destroy the people and the
things that are fighting the machine
right some of the lines there were
dystopian his Elon musk's selfs serving
libertarian views selfs serving
libertarian views well you should have
self-serving libertarian views not to
destroy the world but you should be
self-interested and you should want
limited government and you should then
want to build a community around you and
build cool things and maybe go to other
planets uh that he uh has a messiah
complex uh you know first of I I don't
think that's like clinically right but
people who dream and dream big actually
do change the world often for the better
but also that they make it seem like he
was this guy who just came from
everything and he was always this like
evil thing look at this very famous
picture this has got to be from around
1999 or so it's a very famous picture of
Elon Musk and that's Peter teal when
they had created PayPal so it's not just
that Elon Musk has created all these
cool things now he also created the very
original way that we started doing
Commerce online but look at him he was
just a computer dork he got an awful lot
more hair over the years that's pretty
incredible guess money does buy
everything um but like he was just some
computer nerd who started building
things and dreaming and doing good
things and also that he that this thing
that the implication that he bought
Twitter to turn it into an echo chamber
he bought Twitter and now has opened it
up so that everybody can be on there and
people say horrible things to him all
day long on Twitter like you people all
these lefties can do all these wers can
do is destroy things you're right John
Oliver you can't build anything you you
can't build comedy even and I don't know
what that was with the guy the robot man
in the dancing it's like it's nothing
how about go create something instead of
spending all day long trying to destroy
people but you can't and there's a whole
machine that's actually designed to
destroy people uh most of that is the
mainstream media so we're going to throw
you a couple clips of MSNBC I warn you
in advance but before we do that let's
talk about the wellness company guys I
want to introduce you to the wellness
company and specifically their medical
emergency kit awake doctors like Dr
Peter McCulla started the wellness
company to build a parallel Health Care
system and bring about change in a
corrupt and failing system part of that
change is helping you to take control of
your health and supporting you through
whatever the next thing that gets thrown
our way is most people don't trust trust
Healthcare right now in fact over 40% of
Americans say they would avoid a doctor
or a hospital unless it was a
catastrophic situation that's where the
wellness company's medical emergency kit
comes in eight potentially life-saving
medications for you to keep on hand in
times of need natural disasters supply
chain shortages medical emergencies rest
easy knowing that you have emergency
antibiotics antivirals and
antiparasitics to help keep you and your
family safe the kit includes a
comprehensive guide book so you never
have to guess how much to take or when
to take it if you're like me and you
want to make sure your family's prepared
go to tww c.in and use code Ruben to
save 15% a check out that's TW wc.
health rubben code Ruben for 15% off and
now back to me so okay the machine and
you know this this is been well uh this
has been going on for well over a year
since Elon Musk basically decided to buy
Twitter that he has become the bad guy
right and they are constantly going
after him and the government's looking
into his other businesses and they're
trying to make it seem like he's a Nazi
and a far- right person but we've seen
this script before and of course the
main guy that we've seen this script
about is Donald Trump and they just
replicate the script and and amazingly a
huge percentage of people probably not
you watching this right now but a a huge
percentage of people fall for the same
script over and over so now I want to
take you over to the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and Jen Saki
and don't forget Jen Saki who worked for
the Biden Administration so she is not a
journalist by any stretch uh of the
imagination she is a paid activist who
was a paid liar for this Administration
and then became an even more highly paid
liar over at a televis meal institution
here she is with a little extra this we
thought this was just like a little
extra bonusy Trump Hitler kind of stuff
this week has put on full display the
ways in which our country is living in
two completely different realities there
is one reality let's call it Earth where
there is deep concern right now about a
four times indicted former president who
yesterday continue to Echo the language
of Adolf Hitler of all people by saying
immigrants are quote poisoning the blood
of our country here on Earth there were
some big developments this week in one
of the criminal cases involving that
former president the one where he's
accused of trying to overturn a
democratic election oh and I should note
that here on Earth there was also some
good economic news with the Dow hitting
a new record high and an announcement
that the Federal Reserve is planning to
cut interest rates next year but there
is of course also an alternate reality
right now one in which none of that
matters in this alternate reality
President Biden is plunging the United
States into a depression even though
again the Dow just hit a record high in
this alternate reality President Biden's
age alone makes him unfit to serve while
Trump I would know just three years
younger is somehow seen as the epitome
of strength and vitality and in this
alternate reality it is the current
President Joe Biden who is now the
subject of an impeachment inquiry for a
mysterious and sprawling Scandal no one
can explain involving bribery and
Corruption now there is of course no
evidence at all to suggest that any of
it is true but that is still the story
that is being mainlined into a huge
portion of the country right now really
I say this sometimes but I actually
really like I literally mean it I want
to study these people not well not me I
want someone out there with a little
extra time on their hands to really
start studying these people these people
who see reality and then completely see
the opposite of reality who lie about
everything and know they're lying like I
I just I don't know what that is I don't
know what that is that's in them that
can do that thing uh yes he's four time
indicted zero time convicted so that
doesn't mean anything that doesn't mean
that it's legit right we know like these
the New York charges okay you get it the
age thing no one's going after Biden
because of his age they're going after
Biden because of the slurring the
confusion the exhaustion the crazy
stories the rambling the wandering off
into the forest etc etc the implication
that there is no evidence of anything
related to corruption when it comes to
Joe Biden who fired the Ukrainian
prosecutor and his son was working for a
Ukrainian Energy company and we're in
the middle of a war in Ukraine that we
haven't declared war but we're LLY
funding it do you think something weird
is going on over there also Trump saying
that the immigrants are are poisoning
the blood is not Hitler hitlerian is
that a word it's not hitlerian I just
coined a word I it is a word all right
we'll count that as a word uh in
language the illegal immigrants who are
coming here and we're going to do a
whole bunch about them coming up in a
moment who are coming here are poisoning
the country because we don't know who is
here we don't know what they believe we
don't know what they're doing to our
culture we're watching our institutions
fail our system system is poisoned right
now it absolutely is and we all damn
well know it but let's continue with
what's going on over at MSNBC uh because
they brought on this guy by the name of
Miles Taylor he's a national security
official believe it or not he was hired
by Donald Trump and you know Donald
Trump does have some issues when it
comes to hiring uh but here he is on
MSNBC trying to scare the F out of
everybody Liz Cheney's been talking
about that I am also obsessed with is
kind of what damage he could do within
government without even necessarily
breaking the law like how he could use
the levers of government to bend to his
will you've worked in government what
scares you the
most well the possibilities are almost
Limitless and I spent nearly two years
asking that question to people and I
wrote it in this book blowback but to
try to paint that picture to try to
understand what he would actually do by
talking to all of my former colleagues
at different departments and agencies
under Trump and asking them that
question what will happen in a second
term the biggest concerns for me are on
the National Security side I think
Americans still don't understand the
full extent of the president's powers
and things Donald Trump could do bubble
wrapped in legal that would be damaging
to The Republic and one of those that
I've noted is there's something in the
White House called the Doomsday Book and
for the first time DHS gave
authorization for me to mention this
publicly uh and the fact that there are
concerns that that book which is
supposed to be used to protect the
country in instances of armed foreign
Invasion or Rebellion it's the
president's most extraordinary powers
could be picked up by Trump and used for
domestic political never heard a
president of the United States invoke
potentially to shut down companies or
turn off the internet or deploy the US
military on us
soil all right the Doomsday
Book Trump was President for four years
he didn't use the book last time but now
there's this special book and this guy
with all the hairspray that he used that
morning not that I can really make fun
of him for that uh he's uh he was given
clearance by DHS you can tell them about
the book Let's freak everybody else out
and what might Trump do if he gets
access to this book he might shut off
the internet which they've been
threatening about for years by the way
there is this I mentioned this the other
day but there is this show on Netflix
called Leave the World Behind uh movie
that was produced by Obama and it's
about shutting off the internet they are
predictively programming us for God
knows what but it will most likely be
them who do it the Biden Administration
and these clowns not Trump and you know
I have all my criticisms about Trump
okay that first off the way she asked
that question you worked in the
government what scares you the most you
worked at Best Buy what's freaking you
out you worked at Chipotle what's going
on over there like these these that's
not a question
you bring on these children and these
but they want to keep these people in a
complete state of panic and then you
wonder why people are freaking out why
are people wandering around why is
everybody on prescription drugs why is
everybody constantly uh suffering from
anxiety and all the rest of it it's
because they're telling you that he's
Hitler he's going to use this book to
shut off the Internet it's a lot of
stuff that he's doing constantly
constantly constantly oh and more Hitler
stuff here we go hours Douglas after
making these remarks the former
president um doubled down and wrote a
post saying this illegal immigration is
poisoning the blood of our nation as I
mentioned President Biden and the White
House are comparing this to the words of
Adolf Hitler and specifically the words
that were written in mine comp and I
want to read for folks the comparison
that we see within mine compm so they
understand the gravity of this situation
the poison which has invaded the
national body especially the strong
influx of foreign blood that is from
mine comp as a historian Doug what did
you hear in the former president's
remarks I heard a former president who
is um Jing on fascism there's no
question about that being a line from
mine comp he knows it uh he's been
dabbling in Adolf Hitler his whole life
keeps Hitler speeches at a bedside uh um
minec seems to be the book that's
inspired Trump the most so it's heinous
because it's it's the kind of language
meant to belittle people dehumanize them
uh and when we're not making a an
anti-trump comment when we're saying he
is a fascist guys that really we're
dealing with a fight in our country
between democracy and Fascism and
Trump's telling you that he's not he
doesn't really mind the Hitler
comparison because at heart he admires
Hitler at heart he admires Hitler his
daughter and several of his
grandchildren are Jewish do you know
that Hitler not a fan of the Jews uh as
a general rule uh also that guy there
that historian he's this was his exact
line he keeps Hitler speeches at his bed
how would he know that Doug Doug have
you been sleeping with Don what are you
talking about like really think about it
you think Donald Trump Donald Trump
sleeps with Hitler speeches at his bed
like what do you think he has he has the
tanning cream on the side of the bed
obviously well think about it Trump
wakes up try to picture Trump waking up
right he wakes up little orange stuff
some hairspray what else like what else
would he have he puts on the red tie I
feel like he puts the red tie on before
he even gets like it's just madeup
dribble they just brought on a historian
to claim that he knows what Donald Trump
has on his bedside completely insane but
all right here's just one more
this is just a comp it's just a general
Hitler Trump
compilation we're going to see violence
the likes of which we didn't even see on
January 6th you can't imagine the things
that he's going to do assassinate
generals create Mass internment camps
he's going to shut down this station he
could shoot
you Donald Trump's going to just get out
there start shooting people
assassinating generals we've been
through this before script writers
whoever is writing the simulation right
now could you just write like work a
little harder give me something
fresh let's continue though because a
lot of what is going on here seems to be
related to The Border because obviously
one of the things that got Donald Trump
elected last time and may well get him
elected this time is that uh the
Democrats refuse to defend the Border it
is one of the very few jobs of the
president himself to defend the Border
that's a job of the federal government
right like that's the big government we
have state governments and then we have
the federal government and they're
supposed to protect the Border not only
are they not protecting the Border they
are opening it up they are letting
people in they are sending these people
all across the country and it's like we
just watched this happen in Europe
over the last 78 years and look what has
happened look what has happened to
Germany that led a million people in
look what has happened in France and
look what has happened in Belgium and
look what has happened in England like
we've seen this before and now it's
literally happening right now uh and
thankfully while we have a guy like Elon
Musk with a somewhat free internet and
while we have platforms like Rumble we
are able to see the videos because they
are not being shown on uh MSNBC they're
not being shown on mainstream media uh
so I want to show you this video this is
this is wild this is from Fox News uh
Bill maluan who's doing a great job this
guy is just doing an absolutely great
job at the border check out what's going
on uh on our uh Southern border right
now this is from yesterday I can tell
you we have not yet seen any national
guard down here in lukeville what we
have seen are more more mass illegal
Crossings and more mass processing
taking place we'll step out and give you
a look at the scene here this is a
temporary outdoor area that border
patrol has set up here to process these
illegal immigrants you can see family
units as well as single adult men who
have come in from all over the world
here uh getting processed getting ready
to get put on a border patrol bus where
many of them will be released and likely
heading to a city near you in the coming
days and we'll show you what's been
happening out here take a look at this
video we shot yesterday afternoon right
here in lukeville another massing ining
through a breach in the border wall we
were showing this a couple weeks ago as
well hundreds of people pouring through
the breaches in the border wall Crossing
illegally a lot of them single adults as
I mentioned coming in from all over the
world in this group you're looking at
here there were adult men from Congo
Guinea Sagal others from Colombia and
Ecuador and Harris listen to these
numbers just in this Tucson Arizona
sector in the last three weeks alone
border patrol says they've arrested more
than
54,000 illegal immigrants and that does
not count the gu
away I want you really to think about
this like I'll try to do this with no
sarcasm or anything um we just spent 10
minutes talking about how they call this
man Hitler and they call anyone who's
for you know functional border and Nazi
and a racist and you're a bigot and all
of those things we know nothing about
those people absolutely nothing we don't
know what they believe in we don't know
where they're from what their intentions
are by being here on top of the fact
that it's just it's just immoral not to
defend your border right the whole
purpose of a nation state is to have a
border so you defend the lifestyle of
the people that are within that border
and you decide when to let people in and
how many can come and what your
processes are as it relates to people
coming in and everything else and if you
don't want anyone to come in that's your
National decision and if you want more
people to come in and all of those
things but right now we have an
Administration that not only is being
negligent in their defense of the Border
but then as Bill talks about we get
these people in we know virtually
nothing about them and then we ship them
all over the country
do you think there's a problem right now
do you think that might poison the blood
do you think that that might be a bit of
an issue does that make me Hitler does
that make me a racist to talk about that
but if you and that's the thing what
they do is no matter how honestly you
talk about it they will paint you as a
racist and a Hitler and Trump I think
over the years has just been like fine I
will just dive all in on all of the
crazy language cuz I know what they're
going to do with me
regardless all they have to do right now
Biden you want to do the right thing you
want to stop orange Hitler from coming
back how about defend the Border how
about close the border figure out who's
here and then tomorrow when I do a show
we won't have those videos to show
because you'll have done your job and
then less people might be like you know
that orange Hitler guy he's uh he's not
that important I guess because The
Border's closed they won't do it check
this out this is wild this is yesterday
this is like legit bananas haven't said
bananas in a while Eagle Pass Texas look
what's going on at our border
[Music]
insane again who are these people we
don't know about their belief system
even if we did we have a border you
can't just walk into our country
although I guess you can uh and I want
to continue this with this Ashley
stclair who works over at the Bon B
she's been on the show a couple times
over the years uh she was coming back
from an event a turning point USA event
I believe in Phoenix and she was at the
airport in Phoenix and check this out we
got a couple Clips here uh she found
that they were actually just as bill
maluan was reporting that they send
these migrants these illegal immigrants
who we know nothing of they process them
and then they send them throughout the
country check this out from uh the
Phoenix Airport I'm at the Phoenix
airport right now I'm waiting to board
my flight to New York uh to JFK and it
looks like we have a whole lot of
migrants who are also boarding this
flight that the US taxpayers are paying
for this is what the us taxpayers are
paying for right here premium seats on
Delta that they have people coming here
we're paying for this shipping them out
to New York City because guess what
everywhere else is at capacity so they
have these Sanctuary cities like New
York that they're now shipping these
migrants to that we're all paying for I
texted Ashley right before the show
because I wanted to get a little more
information and she said that you know
she's done a lot of work uh and actual
journalism paying attention to what's
going on with the border and she saw
that a huge amount of these people they
have that kit we'll show you a little
bit more here's just uh here's the
flight she actually took some video on
the
flight
sorry that was a bit more of them
boarding but now here's on her flight
she took this picture and here's her
tweet migrant place next to me in the
premium cabin still has bag from the
processing center a majority of this
flight is migrants bust in from the
processing center can Delta please let
all of their customers know what medical
screenings are being done for these
migrants illegally crossing into our
border for all from all over the world
and being flown on their flights I mean
it really is rather extraordinary if you
if you removed everything else about all
the moral and legal things I just
mentioned about the Border I thought you
know we had these three years of this
crazy pandemic and you know Co is a
thing and are we screening these people
do we know what diseases they're
bringing from Sagal and Congo and some
of these other places again we know
nothing about their Lifestyles and then
they're just literally think about this
you somehow they got to the Mexican
border from Congo Sagal all of these
other places right they get there they
get processed now they're in Phoenix now
we just shipped them all earli now
they're in New York City tomorrow well
we're going to show you what's going on
in New York City in just a second but
then they just show up in New York City
do they have jobs do they have family
there do they have any
assistance and again you wonder why some
people are a little irked at this I want
to show you uh a tweet from ritaa
Rosenfeld here this is uh interesting uh
this is what's going on in New York City
when you wonder about these people that
are just being flown into New York City
and what the f do we do with them US
President Joe Biden's disastrous open
border policy has turned Sanctuary
cities into unrecognizable migrant camps
and New York City is at Ground Zero of
this crisis over
110,000 migrants are on Manhattan
streets more than twice as many as
cities such as Los Angeles and Houston I
mean look at that look at that New York
City was once the greatest city in the
world it was the jealousy of the world
it was the place that everybody wanted
to go and if you could make it in New
York City you could make it anywhere
right and now it has been over run by
crime and homeless and drugs and a and a
taxpayers uh base that is fleeing so
then you have less people paying into
the system and more people mooching off
the system do you think that that can
last for a long time on top of the fact
that virtually every day now there are
pramas rallies all over the city and
they take over Grand Central and they
take over Penn Station and they go for
the Rockefeller Christmas tree and they
have protest outside Fox News and
everywhere else uh just yesterday there
were massive protests yesterday here are
pro pramas demonstrators calling for
intifa revolution outside Grand Central
Terminal and down in the West
Village
re the reolution is only there is only
one
soltion reolution
reolution
[Music]
the NYPD the KKK and the IDF are all the
same I mean these people you get it
these These are brainwashed pawns they
are tools they are being used by powers
that they cannot even imagine they have
no idea you you probably saw the queer
is for Palestine people like these it's
all completely insane but they just take
over city streets and they take over
there's plenty of video you can find it
we're we're not showing you all of it
but they plenty of video of just going
into stores and stopping Commerce people
cannot function cities cannot function
and it really although we've said it
many many times like nobody's coming to
save New York it it is it's just
impossible you think Eric Adams is going
to save New York who's coming who's
coming it's just going to keep getting
worse check out what was happening uh in
Penn Station last night Allah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah sorry folks that's not London
that's not
Paris that's not uh
belua that's New York City and again you
putting aside religion for well not not
putting aside religion if these were
Christian nationalists do you think the
mainstream media might be going crazy
but when you see that people praying
intifa Revolution R River to the Sea how
can a society function like that what if
you were just from let's say you're in
Jersey you're now you're you you took
your kids uh into the city you wanted to
go see what's on Broadway these days
Barbie what's what's playing on Broadway
they got Jersey Boys still going I don't
know you take them to see J you you live
in Jersey you go to New York City to see
Jersey Boys now you're in Penn Station
trying to get uh over onto the New
Jersey Transit uh to get back to Jersey
and then you have all of these people
calling for genocide uh praying all this
stuff like a city cannot function over
time you know I love these throwback
videos here's a little New York City in
the 90s with some fun music to it I
thought we'd play this look at these
people back then in the 90s look a black
guy looks like he might have an early
Maga hat on look at these people going
to work nobody's calling for in
Revolution look at that chick she's out
there doing yeah dude he knows what's up
look at these guys guy with a what's he
carrying there I don't know what he's
doing but look at these functional
people dressed well you can feel that
there was a Vibrance to the city people
are going places for a reason that is
the New York look at that guy look at
that beard look at that beard I think I
saw a nun in there like that's what New
York City used to be like and that
wasn't that long ago that's 20 30 years
ago we had a functional City a place
where people would build businesses you
would come to the New York City to make
your dream whatever that dream might be
and over the last well it's probably
more than a decade but the last
certainly the last two mayors of New
York City for sure there was the
Communist lunatic Bill DeBlasio and then
he got uh he left after two horrible uh
terms and then they got Eric Adams and I
saw it I saw it from the good liberals
Eric Adams won't be as bad as Bill
DeBlasio and it was like of course he
was going to be as bad if not worse here
he is and he wanted this place to be a
sanctuary City that's one of the things
he ran on he wanted New York City
nobody's nobody's illegal everybody can
come and get stuff and all that good
stuff uh here he is on the illegal
immigration crisis he's starting to
realize there might be a problem here we
had to do a real job of explaining to
Everyday New Yorkers that the federal
government has abandoned this important
issue that's a national issue so they're
angry and it's going to come out I'm a
mayor you know
mayor yeah no Sherlock you abandon
your duty yes the the federal government
has abandoned their Duty I agree Biden
you want to impeach Biden over Hunter
Biden you could impeach Biden for not
doing one of his again very few there
aren't many things the president's
supposed to do protect the border is one
of them that would be to me the way you
want to really get rid of this guy
although he's probably just going to
fall down the stairs any of these days
or usually he falls up the stairs uh but
there he you see he's trying to Kick the
Can out of the bucket okay oh it's it's
the federal government's well you
invited everybody to your city right why
don't we have them in Florida because
Des Santos was like you come here we're
kicking you out we're we don't have
we're not a sanctuary State we're not a
sanctuary City now watch this this is
this might be the most incredible video
of all of 2023 Eric Adams two days ago
went on some local show and they're
asking him about you know what what this
whole year has been like listen to his
an this is so unbelievable I I honestly
I thought this was AI the first time I
saw it this is just incredible this is
real enjoy Mr Mayor we've come come to
the end of what was a very eventful 2023
right so when you look at the totality
of the year if you had to describe it
and it's tough to do in one word what
would that word be and tell me why uh
New York uh this is a place where every
day you wake up uh you could experience
everything from a plane crashing into
our Trade Center to a a person who's
celebrating a new business that's open
uh this is a very very complicated City
and that's why it's a greatest on the
globe I can't do this
mogger what first off New York is two
words let's just put that aside for a
second um I was in New York City during
911 um the planes crashing was not one
of the greatest things about the city it
was probably I don't it might have
literally been the worst day of my life
I mean it was was it was UN an
unimaginable tragedy and all of those
things but like what kind of insane
statement is that sum up the ear in one
word New York oh continue planes are
crashing into the Trade Center someone
opened up a pizza shop these people it's
like it brains have been broken I don't
know how to overstate that enough
people's brains are actually broken and
this man has invited all of this into
New York city so again if you live in
New York City and we show you migrants
that come in that are flown in from
Phoenix as we just showed and then
thrown into the streets of New York City
and now there's
110,000 of them in New York City and the
city is stressed and so many people
think of the amount every single person
watching this every single person
watching this knows somebody that has
fled New York City or the greater New
York area since Co right so all of these
people they took their businesses out
they took they took their it's not just
the businesses and the money and the tax
dollars and all that you're taking all
of the good functional people out so
then you're left with less functional
people less productive people
less people that pay into the system but
again it's not just about money it's
about the culture around all that and
the system is stressed and crime is up
and drugs are up and all of the stuff so
what is going on uh with the federal
government though because Eric Adams is
right to I suppose to some degree the
federal government has been negligent in
their Duty uh when it comes to wait do
we have something else here before I
move on what do we got again oh we're
going to watch it one more time we're
going to I mean it's just it's
incredible they want me to watch it
again oh describe it and it's tough to
do in one word what would that word be
and tell me why uh New York uh this is a
place where every day you wake up uh you
could experience everything from a plane
crashing into our Trade Center to a a
person who's celebrating a new business
that's open
what bro what are you talking about
man I'm out man I see what you guys did
there okay okay uh but again Eric Adams
to give the devil his due he is right to
some degree from the earlier clip which
is that the federal government has been
negligent I'm the mayor man what do you
want me to do I always put on my
well-fitting
suit but instead of dealing with the
Border uh it is my belief you know
people keep saying oh they're just
they're either you know Biden
Administration or you know whatever like
to me this is this is completely
intentional you cannot be this negligent
so what are they focused on well fear
not people Joe Biden's out there and
he's working on three new covid vaccines
yes really listen and just listen to all
the slurs and the exhaustion and
everything else and tell me you think
this man should be president for another
four years go we're already begun to
secure fair pricing Clauses and
contracts for new covid vaccines three
new covid vaccines can't see he can't
open his eyes anymore that's I don't
know if that's the botox or what the
slurring and three new covid vaccines
anyway here he continues his eloquent
speech taxpayers already are chipping in
making paying a lot of money for that
hearing at night to get these brilliant
scientists to go out and find cures
find answers to drug problem to to drugs
for with the use of drugs for health
problems yeah yeah yeah that guy will be
fine for the next four years okay fine
but they are still focused on Co again
they are letting people into the country
who they are then sending all over the
place from Co and from Co from Congo and
Sagal and all these other places they
throw them a PL send them all over the
place while they're working on covid
vaccines and trying to freak you out
about that and then we saw this I cannot
believe that this woman is back she
should have been banned to the Nether
world but here we are uh Lianna W
remember this woman this was CNN's like
main covid fear-mongering lunatic and
she's back baby and she's still trying
to freak people out over Co and I know
that hospitals are all getting their
preparedness plans ready to try to
increase capacity but I would say that
also puts the onus on us as well um as
individuals because so many people who
have not yet gotten vaccinated for
example um are able to do so the
vaccination rates for the flu lag well
behind what they were last year and when
you look at the updated Co shot only
about a third of people 65 and older
have gotten that vaccine that includes
nursing home residents only about a
third have gotten the updated Co shot so
there's a lot that we as individuals can
be doing to try to prevent hospitals
from getting overwhelmed as well
important to protect yourselves
especially when so many people are sick
uh Dr Lena W thank you so
much
propoganda that's what that is that is
pure statun propaganda from CNN telling
you to so many people are sick the
headline underneath her hospital beds
for children are nearly full in parts of
the country where where you know what's
funny we had three years of Co I never
saw One hospital that was overrun I
never saw the bodies everywhere where
were the bodies how come no Village in
Africa where they don't have clean water
and they didn't have masks why didn't we
how come not one Village why didn't one
state fail because they didn't do it
right how come none of that happened but
they still Trot out this crazy wench and
you might go Dave I don't really
remember her from back then well we
found something for you do you believe
that races the variables are and what
the messaging should be
my main concern is that we're not going
to reach her immunity because of vaccine
hesitancy and I know that's hard for a
lot of people to believe who desperately
want the vaccine right now and they're
thinking oh well it's just a small
percentage of people who are actually
antivaxers and that's true there is the
anti-science antivaxer contingent but I
think that there are many more people
millions of people who for whatever
reason have concerns about the vaccine
who just don't know what's in it for
them and we need to make it clear to
them that the vaccine is the ticket back
to pre-pandemic life and the window to
do that is really narrowing I mean you
were mentioning Chris about how all
these states are reopening they're
reopening at 100% And we have a very
narrow window to tie reopening policy to
vaccination status because otherwise if
everything is reopened then what's the
carrot going to be how are we going to
incentivize people to actually get the
vaccine so that's why I think the CDC
and the B Administration needs to come
out a lot Bolder and say if you're
vaccinated you can do all these things
here are all these freedoms that you
have because otherwise people are going
to go out and enjoy these freedoms
anyway and I fear a situation of coming
into the fall when we never reach her
immunity and then we get hit by the next
surge of of of covid-19 in the fall
something that we could have prevented
if we just got people vaccinated now
thank you Dr Alena win that is one covid
right there I tell you that much
sorry sorry I had to do it I tried not
to do it I asked the guys if I could do
it I just I couldn't I looked at all my
words and I had nothing left the fact
that that woman is still on television
you know what I mean like I'm in a room
you unvexed you unvexed you unvexed guy
back there unvexed unvaxxed we're all
doing fine never been
better they wanted to lock you in your
home they wanted to tell you what to eat
when you could go outside whether you
could go to your grandmother's funeral
what you were going to inject with
yourself all of this and we will
have no rec for any of these people
right like they will just reappear again
they magically reappear over and over
and over again and because we never have
a reckoning of all of the bad things
that they do to us over time and then
every time a good person tries to stand
up we try to take out that good person
they are just constantly emboldened now
I want to show you a video this is this
is really really good I was really when
I saw this I was like oh there are some
other good people out there that's nice
to see uh this is an Australian Senator
his name is Malcolm Roberts and listen
to this video just going off on clous sh
clous Schwab and the world economic
Forum as per their great reset agenda
which we've talked about a whole a whole
bunch about and I think you can see how
that's related to everything happening
in the world right now instead of
working together to push CLA Schwab's
World economic Forum plan based on
United Nations policies work together
instead for our
country CLA Schwab's Life by
subscription quote is really surom it's
slavery billionaire globalist
corporations will own everything homes
factories Farms cars
furniture and everyday citizens will
rent what they
need if their social credit score
allows the plan of the great reset is
that you will die with
nothing to pull off this evil plan clabs
World economic Forum will need to to
take more than just material possessions
from
Australians senators in this very
chamber today who support the great
reset threaten our privacy freedom and
dignity yes they're in this Senate
chamber so yeah people are waking up
they're waking up in the United States
guys like Elon Musk they're waking up in
Australia and and they are waking up and
we have to keep talking about this and
we have to keep exposing it and
everything else because as especially as
we roll into 2024 with this election
coming up whether it is a migrant crisis
whether it is homas rallies in our
cities whether it is covid and more
vaccinations and everything else whether
it is the internet going out and Donald
Trump's Doomsday Book or the crazy list
of things that we can think of and that
we cannot think of that are that are
unfolding right in front of us that
could be tossed right in our laps we
better be prepared you you better have
your head on straight otherwise whatever
is going to happen over the next year is
going to break you too if you're
watching this show you probably are not
broken yet like there are moments where
they could have broken all of us there
was a moment even in my life like two
years ago where we were considering
getting vac because of all of the
pressures right so they can break
everybody and and now we're in a real
pressure cooker situation because of
this election coming and you can just
feel it you can just feel everything
that we've just showed you the people on
our streets all the covid stuff like
it's just going to be a whacked out
crazy year so what's one of the tools of
course that you can use to defend
yourself well James Lindsay who's been
on the show many times and he is one of
the best I would say
explainers of what this cultural Marxist
movement is and how to fight it uh he
gave a nice talk on uh sort of the
effective ways that you can go about
dismantling some of this
stuff another principle that helps with
this is show don't tell
if I stand here and tell you things
they're not
believable it's married truth and lies
it is not believable but if I show you
this is literally what they wrote this
is literally what they said this is
exactly what they're doing here's where
the money went whatever it is you show
don't tell it
works woke stuff is virtually
unbelievable even when you're looking
straight at it but I want you to think
about one
character that goes by Libs of Tik tock
and think of how many things that you
saw that you weren't told about and how
it changed your mind about what's
happening in this country show don't
tell is a very powerful thing I gave up
a while back in my podcast basically
just became me reading papers because I
was like read repressive tolerance
everybody read nobody read it I think
like five people read it so I said you
know what I'm going to do a podcast I'm
going to read repressive tolerance to
you now like 300,000 people heard me
read it show don't tell so what he's
referencing there is the libs of Tik Tok
Twitter Twitter account that we've shown
a lot of their stuff over the years Libs
of Tik Tok this this girl higher Ric
totally nice girl I've had dinner with
her many times lovely lovely actually
she's never been on the show which we
should make happen all she started doing
was sharing videos of the crazy social
justice warriors on Twitter so she
didn't manipulate the videos in any way
she uh she would literally go to Tik Tok
there would be crazy people with all of
the gender stuff the Neo rist stuff and
then she just put it on Twitter and then
people started calling her a racist and
a white supremacist and a neonazi she's
an Orthodox Jewish woman okay uh because
she was just showing what these people
were saying which they were already
putting out publicly and the ADL tried
to take her out and Media Matters tried
to take her out and a whole bunch more
so you have to expose this stuff so
that's what we try to do here and now I
want to connect us to one other thing to
go full circle we start at the top of
the show with that ridiculous John
Oliver a very very average human being
at best going after an extraordinary
human being Elon Musk right Elon Musk
building things doing things dreaming
that video we showed you yesterday at
the end where he gave such a beautifully
eloquent speech about what the human
condition's all about and what the human
spirit's all about and that we can do
amazing things and imagine if we could
go to other planets and understand inter
Stellar travel like all of the things
that were once the dreams of generations
like we could still do all that but you
have this very very average comedian
John Oliver trying to take him out and
that is a large part of the problem we
have average people who out of jealousy
are trying to take out the good people
and we will end Today's Show with
Alabama football coach Nick Sabin
talking about mediocre people versus
high
Achievers mediocre people don't like
high Achievers and high Achievers don't
like mediocre people so if everybody
doesn't buy into the same principles and
values of the organization at the same
high standard you're never going to be
successful that's it it that's it there
is a bunch of mediocre
people they are the John Olivers they
are the MSNBC hosts the CNN hosts they
are the quote unquote journalist class
and every time someone tries to do
something good Elon Musk Jordan Peterson
whoever it might be Donald Trump doesn't
matter who it is they try to do
something different they try to actually
address a problem they try to build
something new they spend their life
trying to take these people out so you
have to decide whether you want to be an
extraordinary person or a mediocre
person and not all of us have
extraordinary talents like every I think
everyone does have something like
there's something I think innate in
everybody and you have to kind of figure
out what it is and figure out how to go
get it and all that stuff but the least
you could do is not destroy the people
who are doing the good stuff we're in a
time of Destruction but I think it's
better to be a builder if you have not
subscribed guys please do at rumble.com
rubben report we got a postgame show
coming up for you at Ruben report. loal
.c in about 30 seconds new Twitter
account Ruben report show that's where
we're putting up all the clips uh and we
have a funny uh I believe we have to
call this AI we don't want to dupe you
people uh this is a Karin jeanpierre
Barack Obama mashup for a cold close and
we'll see you on the other side ciao you
know there's been zero evidence zero
evidence you can ask me how can I I mean
Obama be the hidden Puppet Master for
this Administration but there's no
evidence there's wait wait there's no
evidence there's no evidence that Obama
is Joe's Puppet Master there's none
absolutely
none none and that is just a fact you
can't say that it looks like my hair is
the dirty mop the janitor is looking for
you can't say that it looks like I
lazily slapped on some of Big Mike's
lipstick and horrific eyes Shadow don't
even look that close that's a waste of
time
[Music]